Speaker 1: Well, Jared Kushner and Ivanka
Trump have now been subpoenaed by the special
counsel. And this is a very, very big deal which
potentially will lead simply to hundreds of times
over many hours pleading the fifth. Depending
on how it goes, The New York Times reports Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump subpoenaed in January
6th investigation. And you might be saying,
David, sir, hold on. I thought that ended
because Congress ended. This is not that
investigation. The last congressional term
ended, better said. And now Republicans have
taken over. This is not that investigation.
This is the special counsel. The article says
the special counsel overseeing the inquiry into
Trump's efforts to retain power after the 2020
election wants the former president's daughter
and son in law to testify to a grand jury.
The decision by the special counsel, Jack Smith to
subpoena Trump and Kushner underscores how deeply
into Trump's inner circle Smith is reaching and
is the latest sign that no potential high level
witness is off limits. The article also says
the disclosure about the subpoena comes two
weeks after it was revealed that Smith subpoenaed
former Vice President Pence. Pence plans to fight
that subpoena, invoking his role as president of
the Senate to argue that it violates the speech
or debate clause of the Constitution. As far as
these subpoenas go, quote, It is unclear whether
Trump will seek to block whether Donald Trump will
seek to block Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner from
testifying on the grounds of executive privilege.
As he has tried with some other witnesses, both of
them served as White House officials in the Trump
administration, Trump declined to try to stop them
from testifying before the House committee. An
aide to Ivana and Jared didn't respond with a
request for comment. It's ironic how the Trump
cult often overlooks how Jared Kushner received
billions from Saudi Arabia, which is a country
they love to demonize. But they're obsessed
about Hunter Biden's laptop and Jared Kushner,
who admittedly we don't talk about that often
on this program either. He and Ivanka seem to
have kind of decided for our personal image this
entire thing was very bad. And there are articles
about how, you know, in the waning days of the
Trump administration, they wanted to just kind of
like return to their old social lives in New York
City. And a lot of people didn't want to welcome
them because they were understandably disgusted.
So they ended up I think it was like moving to
Miami, but it's a whole mess. But Jared, any vanga
are at least somewhat connected to the reality of
how they are now seen. And the truth is that they
don't get the scrutiny that they probably deserve
as individuals who were far more involved with the
Trump administration than were Eric and Don JR for
example, and the double standard with the Hunter
Biden laptop is of course wild and we reasonable
people could point to them and say, you know,
they made hundreds of millions of dollars while
serving for the government thanks to nepotism and
somehow that doesn't deserve an investigation. But
Hunter Biden, when we know 99% of the Hunter Biden
story and his drug issues and the entire thing,
he had nothing to do with government. He had
nothing to do with Joe Biden's vice presidency.
He has nothing to do with Joe Biden's presidency.
They want extensive investigations and hearings
and endless resources and millions of dollars of
taxpayer money going to the Hunter Biden laptop.
But they're not even thinking about Jared Jared in
a bunker. One of the things I do think, however,
about Ivanka, my instinct right now, given the
distance that Ivanka and Jared have kind of put
between themselves and Trump's 2024 campaign,
Ivanka has kids that I think she actually does
care about. I think she would throw her dad under
the bus if it meant saving herself and her family.
The most likely outcome at the end of this entire
subpoena is an eight hour deposition where Ivanka
pleads the fifth 500 or a thousand times. I still
think that's the most likely outcome. But if it
really came down to self-preservation, I actually
do think that Ivanka would do what she needed
to do to maintain her immediate family unit.
But that's just a guess. Let me
know what you think in the comments.